welcome back so I'm really excited to do
this lecture on reinforcement learning
I've been wanting to do this for a long
time those of you who know me know that
I love control theory and machine
learning and reinforcement learning is
kind of at this sweet spot between these
two super important fields okay so
reinforcement learning is essentially a
branch of machine learning that deals
with how to learn control strategies to
interact with a complex environment okay
and so one of the ways I think about
this the way I'm going to define this is
the reinforcement learning is a
framework for learning how to interact
with the environment from experience
this is a very biologically inspired
idea this is what animals do so through
trial and error through experience
through positive and negative rewards
and feedback there they learn how to
interact with their environment ok good
so before I jump in I want to show some
motivating videos I really like this one
where reinforcement learning is used to
learn how to walk in this artificial
environment and there's a lot of papers
like this where people use reinforcement
learning as kind of an optimization
framework to learn how to control a
complex system in this case a bipedal
Walker often in a simulated environment
and this just looks really cool and it's
a difficult control problem this is a
really hard non-linear control problem
now the goal would be to take what you
learn here and start to port that over
into the real world to make better
robots and better actual physical agents
that can interact with the world
alongside us to learn how to learn like
humans and animals do so another video I
love this is my dog Mordecai and my wife
has trained him this is a treat on his
nose to hold the treat on his nose until
she says ok after which he can then grab
the treat and eat it this is not an easy
trick to learn and this again this goes
to show you anytime you anybody who's
trained an animal a dog or any other
animal has done some type of
reinforcement learning or reinforcement
training ok and so that's actually where
the word reinforcements comes from is
that in in animal systems in human
systems you in you reinforce good
behavior with rewards like treats okay
and so that's kind of the whole name of
the game here is learning a good control
strategy or a good set of actions
through positive reinforcement good so
that's what we're gonna talk about today
I'm gonna walk you through the framework
so I want to disentangle there is a
reinforcement learning framework kind of
the framework for how you learn to
interact with the environment and then
there's a hard optimization problem for
how you actually optimize the agents
actions or policies given that framework
and those are kind of two pieces that
we're going to talk about today and then
in a future video I'm going to talk
about kind of deep reinforcement
learning or reinforcement learning with
modern techniques and deep neural
networks and some of the incredible
applications and and performance that
you can get out of those systems good
so also I'll point out you can follow
updates on these videos at eggin steve
on twitter please like please subscribe
hit the bell so you get notifications
and comment below tell me what you want
to see more of tell me what you like or
don't like oftentimes people in the
comments provide a lot of really
important useful information that I
might have left out of these videos so I
think it's also a big service to other
people watching these all right so we're
gonna jump in and we're gonna build this
reinforcement learning framework from
the ground up from scratch and so at the
heart of it you start with an agent and
an environment and the agent I actually
like the name agent because it implies
some agency the agent gets to take
actions to interact with the environment
so in the first example and I'm gonna
have a few examples we're going to talk
about a mouse in a maze so the agent is
a mouse the environment is a maze the
mouse gets to measure its current state
in the environment so it measures that
state s notice that it doesn't measure
the full state the mouse does not have a
top-down view of the whole maze it just
knows where it is right now and where it
was in the past and then the add Mouse
gets to take some action a it gets to
make some decision about what to do next
okay so it could turn left it could turn
right or it could go
forward in this case and only until the
very end of the maze does the mouse
actually get a reward are so these
rewards are very sparse few and far
between in this case if it goes to the
very end of the maze it might get a
piece of cheese actually my wife tells
me that when they do training
experiments for rats they really like
fruit loops and it looks adorable
because a fruit loop is gigantic to a
mouse or to a rat
but the moral of the story here is that
this agent gets to make some decisions
it has control over its actions so it
has agency and the environment it gets
to measure where it is in the
environment and occasionally it gets
rewards very occasionally it gets
rewards and so part of the the goal of
this system is to learn what actions
actually caused it to get a reward or
not okay and this is in some sense in
the machine learning lingo this is
called semi-supervised learning so if
the mouse got a reward at every single
stage of the maze if at every correct
turn it got a piece of cheese that would
just be regular supervised learning and
those rewards would be called labels
they would tell you yes you did the
right thing or no you did not do the
right thing but because the reward here
is time-delayed it comes at the very end
of the game or very sporadically and
it's not linked to every single
individual action we call that time
delay the label a reward and this
becomes a semi supervised learning
problem so it's still supervised in the
sense that there is supervisory feedback
telling the agent what worked and what
didn't but it's not nearly as much
information as in classical supervised
learning and that's one of the major
challenges of reinforcement learning is
that these these labels are extremely
rare and it's very hard to tell what
actions gave rise to actually getting
that reward so this is a much harder
optimization problem and often times
requires much more data and much more
trial and error and I'm going to talk
about that good I also like to think
about the the game of chess or checkers
or tic-tac-toe basically games in
general where the agent basically there
are some rules of the game
and you get to make a finite set of
actions to interact with that
environment now in the case of chess
it's interesting because the environment
is not just the rules of the game
there's also an adversarial opponent
trying to beat you there so you're
trying to beat the opponent you're
trying to checkmate the other to the
other side and they are trying to beat
you and so that's really interesting is
that the rules of this game are trying
to you know there's an active player on
the other side in this environment good
you also might be a terminator trying to
rule the world or try to learn how to
walk I actually think that sounds kind
of funny that in the matrix neo is
actually the agent from a reinforcement
learning standpoint trying to learn the
rules of the matrix which is the
environment okay so let's go back to the
chess example because I think the chess
example really exemplifies a lot of the
issues with reinforcement learning so
we're going to use this as kind of our
exemplar problem at the end of the day
the big challenge in reinforcement
learning is to design a policy of what
actions to take given a state s to
maximize my chance of getting a future
reward that's all that this agent can do
is decide on a policy now this is called
a policy and not a control law for a lot
of reasons partly because the
environment is is not deterministic its
probabilistic and so this policy is also
gonna be probabilistic okay so my policy
PI given a state and an action basically
it tells me what is my probability of
taking action a given that I'm currently
in state s and again this is
probabilistic because I might decide on
playing a mixed strategy I might a
normal control system like swinging up a
pendulum out of carts the rules never
change the system is always given by F
equals MA and so my control law also is
deterministic and never changes but in
the game of chess maybe my opponents
kind of random so maybe or maybe I'm
just learning how to play so what I'm
gonna do with my policy is maybe 80% of
the time I'm gonna move my pond you know
this way but 20% of the time I'm gonna
try this other move just in case my
environment changes or just in case
yeah just in case you know something
different happens that time so you're
gonna use a probabilistic policy to
explore and optimize the rewards coming
from your environments good and you get
to take actions eh that's the whole
point is that once you have this policy
and you know you know what is the
probability of taking an action given a
state and then you just run that policy
and you see how much rewards you get
good and this all happens in time so you
take actions at time step one time step
two and so on and so forth you measure
the state at time one time two time
three all the way up to st and there are
rewards that you could be getting at
each of these actions and each of these
measurements now most of the time these
are gonna be null or empty you're not
gonna get any rewards until maybe the
very end of the game of chess but in
principle you could get rewards at some
points along the way and again the game
of chess is a really good example of how
hard this is because you might create a
policy of what you think is the right
thing to do in chess to beat your
opponent but you only get one reward at
the very end of the game maybe I played
a great game of chess and I made one
mistake and I lose the game do I throw
away that whole sequence of actions how
do you figure out what actions were good
and what actions were bad that's very
very hard optimization problem and
that's at the absolute heart of
reinforcement learning okay so part of
helping design a good policy is
understanding what is the value of being
in a certain state s given that policy
PI so once I choose a policy I can as I
can start to learn what is the value of
each state of the system of each board
position in chess for example based on
what is the expected reward I will get
in the future if I start at that state
and I enact that policy I'm gonna say
that again that's a mouthful so the
value of a state s given a policy PI is
my expectation of how much reward I'll
get in the future if I start in that
state and I enact that policy and
there's this gamma to the T which is a
discount rate and so what this is saying
is that I am slightly discounting my
future rewards compared to my immediate
rewards so
is a constant between zero and one that
basically tells you how much you favor
getting a reward right now versus far in
the future and this is you know
intimately related to economic theory
psychology that you know generally
people are more eager to get a reward
now then wait for a delayed reward much
later okay but the basic idea is that
you can start to understand this policy
and what policies are good or bad based
on what are good board positions what
are good value functions and this kind
of is how a human would play is that you
might so the the the set of all states
of a chessboard is combinatorially lard
there's too many to count
you could never hold them all in your
mind but we start creating rules of
thumb of what are good board positions
so for example if I take my opponent's
queen but I still have a queen
I'm much I probably have a better
expected chance of winning and getting a
reward and so you might just count the
points on the board and that would give
you some proxy for the value of a given
state that's one very rudimentary value
function that you could use and over
time as you play and gain mastery you
might refine your value function and get
a better idea of kind of what matters in
the game okay and that's also then going
to help you refine your policy to get to
those good states good
so in this large framework again this is
the reinforcement learning framework the
goal is then to optimize your policy to
maximize your future rewards so at the
end of the day it's an optimization
problem to solve for pi so usually we
think of our environment as not being
fully deterministic like we do in
classical mechanics and classical
control systems often and instead we
think of our environment as being
somehow there's a random or a stochastic
component so these are called Markov
decision processes
mdps and what that means is that if we
are in a state s now and I take an
action a now there is some probability
of me going to a new state s at the next
time step and I could go to multiple
different states and it's kind of you
you roll a dice and you go to that next
state okay so I actually think about
backgammon I think that's a great
example of a game that
has rules it has a deterministic element
but at every turn your rolling died and
that gives you this kind of random
Markov decision process so there's a
probability of going from my current
state and action to the next state s and
that again that makes it hard to
optimize these policies and that's why
these policies have to be probabilistic
in nature because your environment is
probabilistic in nature so the credit
assignment problem I've mentioned before
it's this idea that because your awards
are often very sparse and infrequent
it's very hard to tell what action
sequence was actually responsible for
getting that reward this issue was
recognized as early as the 1960s by
Minsky and it's been one of the central
it's the central challenge and
reinforcement learning and it has been
for six decades this is the problem that
people are still working on today is how
to beat the credit assignment problem
and so a couple of key words I think are
important are dense versus partial
rewards so again the game of chess has
very sparse rewards you only know if you
win when you checkmate or when you are
checkmated and you don't necessarily get
concrete Ward's at intermediate
intervals if you had denser rewards if
some if there if you were playing with a
more knowledgeable like master and they
were telling you move after move oh I
wouldn't move that because then I'll do
this or no that's a really good move
because that makes this structure that's
it's a really strong you know position
they would be giving you extra dense
rewards and they would be helping you
learn faster but in general if you have
sparse rewards then reinforcement
learning is very sample inefficient to
use machine learning terminology meaning
if I only got sparks for rewards I would
have to play many many many many many
times I'd have to have tons of examples
to learn a good optimal policy given
those sparse rewards so sparse rewards
and the credit assignment problem make
it very hard to learn through
optimization what the right policy is
and that's related to sample efficiency
so in general what we do in a lot of
systems is called rewards shaping where
even if you get an infrequent reward
an expert human might build a proxy
reward so that you get more dense
intermediate rewards on the way to this
final reward and so an expert human
would basically guide the learning
process by giving more dense rewards
intermediately that's called reward
shaping okay good so now we're going to
talk about how again the ultimate goal
is to optimize this policy so there's
lots and lots of strategies for this
optimization problem and remember I'm
gonna go back and say all of machine
learning and all of control theory
almost our optimization problems they
are you can pose these as hard
non-linear non convex optimization
problems and then in the case of machine
learning you solve them with data okay
in the case of control you solved them
subject to the constraints of the
dynamics this is no different this is at
the intersection of machine learning and
control theory and reinforcement
learning is again a big optimization
problem within this framework and so to
optimize this policy s and a given
measurements of your rewards given this
this sporadic feedback there are lots of
strategies so there's differential
programming so reinforcement learning
and game theory kind of grew up together
and differential programming is one of
the optimization techniques Monte Carlo
is an old strategy for optimizing these
policies just try a bunch of stuff kind
of randomly temporal difference is like
an optimal balance between differential
programming and Monte Carlo so it kind
of finds the sweet spot of both of these
and its model free so it doesn't require
you have any model of the system and
it's related to the bellman optimization
so so bellman was one of the pioneers of
optimal control theory and also laid a
lot of the foundations that are used in
reinforcement learning today now in the
reinforcement learning problem and this
is true again for most of machine
learning is that there's this balance
and control theory for that matter
between exploration and exploitation so
this policy PI usually we're gonna
parameterize this we're gonna have some
parameters we're gonna try to optimize
those parameters to win the game to get
them
now how much effort how how much do I
put into optimizing a strategy or
exploiting a strategy and how much
effort do I go to try new things that
might that might not work but might also
give me better rewards things I've never
tried before how many you know how much
effort am I going to use to explore good
policies versus to exploit a policy I
think is the best one and this is always
a challenge I'm not going to talk too
much about this I talk about this a lot
in other videos but this is a
fundamental challenge in machine
learning and control theory is this
exploration exploitation balance and
it's a big problem in reinforcement
learning also policy iteration is so
basically you set up a dynamical system
where based on your rewards you
iteratively update the policy to make it
better and better over time based on new
information based on better information
from new rewards that's policy iteration
and there are lots of strategies to do
this so I'm just going to name a bunch
of them so you can use simulated
annealing evolutionary optimization
gradient descent and you can use all of
the modern tools in neural networks and
machine learning stochastic gradient
descent atom optimization
so a lot of really interesting new work
is happening just in the last 10-15
years using deep learning to optimize
these policies okay good so I'll just
give you some cool examples so this is
one of my favorite examples of learning
how to catch a ball in a cup this is a
fun kids game and so an expert human
first off gives the robot like one
example to show that if possible and
then after imitation learning the robot
gets to through trial and error notice
that there's a white screen and the cup
is blue and the ball is red so it's
using visual information from a camera
and after a few iterations it's actually
getting pretty close I think this isn't
so different from how a child would
learn you know kids not going to learn
this in two trials or three trials it
might take a few dozen times before it
actually gets close and then learns how
to catch the ball in the cup after 45
trials it's getting very close it
bounced right off and I don't know if it
will get it at 60 I think it
barely misses but it's getting very very
close after 62 catching it in the in the
cup and finally after a hundred trials
this system has actually learned the
rules of the game the physics of how to
get that ball in the cup
very simple robotic example but it's
also pretty interesting and in this
videos not not that recent but very
interesting to show that it is possible
to learn a real physical system this is
another example I love this is called
the Pilko learner I encourage you to go
read all about Pilko in this case
they're learning kind of how to swing up
and stabilize a pendulum on a cart and
again they are using some combination of
trial and error and a physical model to
you know learn how to do this very
efficiently with very few samples so you
couldn't learn how to do this without
learning a model or without having a
model of the physics Newton's laws F
equals MA
if you just actually I tried this I
downloaded some code in MATLAB and
played around with this just to learn if
you could swing up a pendulum it took
like eight hours on my laptop and
thousands and thousands and thousands of
trials very sample inefficient to learn
like the random control signal that gets
you near the upright position where you
can start to stabilize it so a lot of
trial and error if you don't have a
model so the Pilko learner in some
senses model is leveraging the fact that
there is physics we do know physics we
do have models to learn this much much
faster and much more efficiently many
fewer samples and I forget which which
trial were on but after trial five or
six or seven it actually does learn how
to get this thing up and stabilize I
think trial six is gonna get really
really close let's see alright so I
notice that the human does have to get
this thing back down to zero it's
guiding the humans guiding this process
all along alright so in trial six it's
gonna get really close and almost do it
and I think in Charles seven it's
actually gonna figure it out you're
gonna have to go watch the video to see
what happens okay so again this is our
framework for learning we're trying to
optimize this policy one last thing I'll
tell you
about is q-learning so instead of just
learning the policy and the value
functions separately in q-learning you
can kind of learn them both at the same
time so there's this cue function it's
not just a function of the state s it's
a function of the state and the action
and it tells you what is the quality of
being in that state and taking that
action so it kind of combines the value
and the policy you can almost think of
it as like a value function of the state
and the action assuming I do the
smartest thing in the future that I can
and the best thing in the future and so
I'll walk you through what this could
look like so the way that you update
this quality function is you take your
old quality function and then when you
get a reward you basically update this
alpha is a learning rate gamma again is
the discount rate and what you're doing
this max of Q in the future basically
says I'm assuming that I'm always doing
the best thing I possibly can in the
future and if I do the best thing in the
future kind of what is the quality of my
current state and action so I'm gonna
I'm gonna say this again this is a
little animal seems a little circular
but it's a really nice way of combining
the policy and the value into one
function that you can learn and again
you can learn with this with a deep
neural network nowadays it says given a
state s and an action a and assuming I
do the best thing I can in the future
what is the quality of being in that
state and taking that action and this is
really nice because if you actually know
the quality function then once I find
myself in a state s I just have to look
across all of the out all of the actions
a and pick the one with the best quality
so it's a really nice way of choosing an
action given this quality function when
I find myself at state s I just picked
the action that gives me the best
quality and I enact that action and if I
do that in the future I will maximize my
value and that gives me a policy so
that's really cool okay I guess another
thing I think is super interesting is
hindsight and replay so again when we
talk about the credit assignment problem
and thus partial rewards problem in that
inverted pendulum example that I ran in
MATLAB it took a really really long time
before this thing actually got
near the upright position where it could
start getting rewards and so what you do
in hindsight replay is instead of
throwing out all of the data that
doesn't actually get you a reward what
you do is you say maybe I maybe my a
system my set of actions would be good
for a different reward so maybe in that
ball in a cup example instead of you
know if I didn't get the ball in the cup
maybe the ball went over here what I do
is I look back at replay that event and
I say well maybe someday I'll actually
want to do this other thing that I just
did so I better remember that and I
would encode that that was a good action
sequence for a different reward
structure not the reward I want of
getting the ball in the cup but this
other word of getting the ball over here
and then by learning how to get into
these different states you get a lot
more reinforcement a lot more like kind
of artificial rewards and you learn more
about the physics and the dynamics of
the system about this kind of enhanced
value value and so high insight replay
has been an absolutely critical advance
in making these more data efficient and
learning harder tasks that involve a
more complex state space and it's much
more what a human would do right like
maybe I'm playing tennis and I mess up
you know some some aspect of of hitting
the ball and it goes in a different
direction than I thought but maybe in
the future that's exactly what I'm gonna
want to do and so I'm gonna catalog that
back and when I need to do that in the
future I'm gonna have use that
information so it's much more memory
efficient yeah sorry reward efficient
sample efficient okay good so in this
video I've talked about reinforcement
learning which is a framework for
learning from experience how to interact
with the environment so in the next
lecture I'm going to talk about how to
do this with neural networks and some of
the really exciting advances in the
field all right thank you